frédéric reiss merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
à l'heure où le président de la
république essaye par tous les moyens de
faire baisser le chômage
je voudrais vous alerter sur un dossier
dont les conséquences pour l'emploi sont
évidentes
votre gouvernement a annoncé un
investissement de 1,5 milliard pour
renouveler les trains intercités cette
excellente nouvelle fut accueilli avec
soulagement par l'ensemble de la filière
ferroviaire est aussi par les usagers
car les problèmes de vétusté de sécurité
de fiabilité d'attractivité commerciale
sont criants l'état qui est
décisionnaire sur le renouvellement du
matériel
en tant qu'autorités organisatrices doit
s'engager financièrement avec la sncf un
matériel avec un haut niveau de confort
de service est prêt se pose aujourd'hui
la question déterminante des délais et
du montage juridique les contrat cadre
signé en 2009 avec alstom et bombardier
sont toujours d'actualité je rappelle
que seulement 250 trains régiolis ont
été commandés sur les 1000 annoncer 4000
emplois dans toutes les régions de
france sont concernés sur des sites qui
n'ont aucune visibilité au delà de 2017
une commande maintenant avec le
contrat-cadre favoriserait la continuité
industrielle avec une production de
train dès 2018
si le gouvernement opte pour des appels
d'offres le risque et il est majeur est
une période de quatre ans de rupture de
charge avec à la clé des
restructurations et des fermetures de
sites
car les premiers trains ne sortirait que
fin 2022
les conséquences industrielles
pourraient être catastrophiques avec un
gros risque social dès les premiers mois
de 2010 est quelle décision allez vous
prendre pour le développement de la
filière ferroviaire française qui offre
de réelles opportunités de création
d'emplois merci la parole est à monsieur
alain vidalies secrétaire d'état chargé
des transports de la mer et de la pêche
merci à monsieur président monsieur le
député votre question concerne l'avenir
des trains d'équilibré du territoire
puisque c'est dans ce cadre à la suite
du rapport qui a été fait par la mission
parlementaire présidée par philippe du
on que j'avais annoncé au mois de
juillet une feuille de route pour
répondre à la fois aux nécessité de
faire des économies sur l'ensemble des
trains d'équilibré du territoire dont je
rappelle que le déficit était passé de
200 millions à 400 milliards on a
pratiquement quatre ans et dans cette
feuille de route il y avait une
perspective plus positive c'était celle
d'acheter du matériel notamment pour
servir les grandes lignes sur le
territoire la volonté des élus c'est
d'avoir des trains qui circulent à 200 à
l'heure est à quai au niveau de service
la problématique aujourd'hui vous l'avez
de préciser c'est qu'il existe un marché
ce qu'on appelle un marché ouvert sur
étagère andy qui permettrait de répondre
à cette demande mais nous avons une
question qui est aujourd'hui toujours à
l' expertise juridique c'est de savoir
si ce marché peut être utilisé pour du
matériel qui a des spécificités
différentes notamment sur la vitesse
puisque ce qui a été demandé notamment
par l'association des régions de france
c'est d'avoir des trains qui puisse
aller à 200 kilomètres à l'heure donc
cette expertise est en cours
je vous donne une indication nous
donnerons une réponse définitive pour
votre question probablement le 18
février un moment d'une feuille de route
nouvelle sur l'avenir des thés haute et
nous nous sommes bien conscients de ces
enjeux nous en avons examiné avec
emmanuel macron et nous essaierons
naturellement de prendre une décision
qui soit sérieuse sur le plan juridique
qui prennent en compte les objectifs
industriels que vous avez posé mais qui
aussi répondre à l'attenté de ses trains
d'équilibré du territoire dont l'avenir
est très important pour l'état qu'est
l'autorité organisatrice
merci monsieur le ministre la séance des
questions au gouvernement et terminer la
séance est suspendue